Sicario to Soldado follows CIA agent
matt graver played by josh brolin and
hitman alejandro Gillick as they once
again tried to take down cartels within
Mexico as with the first film agent
graver isn't exactly playing by the rule
book and when the duo kidnapped the
daughter of a drug lord in a false flag
operation designed to incite war between
rival cartels the mission goes awry
throughout this video I will be
discussing the movies ending and key
plot points and so there will be heavy
spoilers with that out the way
I'm definition and this is my ending
explained video for Sicario 2 using the
excuse that terrorists within the u.s.
of gaining entry through the Mexican
border the CIA are given reason to enter
the country and carry out assignments
against the cartels during one campaign
the CIA decided that carrying out
attacks on the two main cartels will
make both believe that it is there
opposition attacking them and will
retaliate killing each other in the
process one of their key attacks is when
the CIA kidnapped one of the cartel
kingpin store and they hypothesized that
they will be able to return the leaders
child and make it look like they rescued
her which will gain them good favor with
the drug lords this trick backfires when
the cartels and the kingpins door are
realized that they are being fooled and
this puts Gillick who is tasked with
returning the child behind enemy lines
the CIA disavow all knowledge of this
mission and Gillick is left trying to
protect the door or was the cartels
right to hunt him down attempting across
the border gillich is shot and left for
dead was aging graver manages to rescue
the daughter believing that Gillick is
dead graver abandons him and returns to
the US with the child in the film's
epilogue we see that Gillick has tracked
down an inner drug mule and using him he
begins his journey to kill more of the
drug cartels within Mexico ending the
film we tease another sequel whether it
will connect though is a foot abate
be interested to see where this plotline
goes it's a shame that this film wasn't
connected to the first and emily Blunt's
character is missing throughout that's
with my first ending explaining video on
Sicario I believe that she has not
returned because she realized she was
not cut out to work in the shady
business and this film only elevates
that threat showing just how bad things
have really gotten when the CIA needs to
do covert operations in order to gain
control it's once again a
thought-provoking look at the war on
drugs and I highly enjoyed it so what
did you think of Sicario - do you think
it lived up to the first film and what
did you take from the movie make sure
you check out my Sicario story recap and
the explained video linked at the end of
this one it discusses the first film and
provides a lot of subtext to this one so
it's definitely worth your time if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel as I release
ending explained discussions weekly and
they'll definitely be a film you're a
fan of again thanks very much for taking
the time to watch this and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]